going out to uh cincinnati ohio to kick
off
the show today is gonna be rick rick
good afternoon how can
uh ken coleman and i help
hey guys uh some old debt
been charged off for a while three
credit cards
and a um
a car repossession so the credit cards
in total for the three way to about uh i
played to be
about eighteen hundred dollars and
the repossession uh which is charged off
like i said
is about ten thousand eight hundred
dollars now i have enough money
in the account to pay off all of that uh
through
some savings um so
i don't really need anything as far as
credit-wise
i know they get charged off
uh in about seven years after or
we stopped reporting or hurting my
credit about seven years after they get
charged off
that's not the case always right oh okay
i'm sorry
i'll be honest with you man you know i
paid off some credit cards
um that were in collections i was in
charge-offs
when i was young and these credit card
companies are very very interesting bro
like very very interesting and so here's
the thing that i think a lot of people
need to need to understand about that
and will answer your question but i just
want to make sure i educate you so you
know
um yeah any time that they just go in
there and just put
a date or any time they touch that
account and they update something on
your credit report
that starts the seven years totally over
okay and so i don't want you to think
like well if i leave it alone today it's
been on there for two years i got five
more years i'll be good in five years no
in four years they'll sell it to another
collection agency it starts to seven
years totally all the way over
all right so how much do you have in
your savings account right now
rick uh about 20 000.
okay you got 20k what do you make a year
uh about 60. okay you make 60k
a year you have 20 thousand dollars in
your savings account
uh what's your question should you pay
it off i mean or
or should you not like what's your
question yeah
i mean should i pay it off i mean it's
it's a large chunk
to take out of my account yeah um
i mean i i guess that's not going to go
away so
i need to pay it off right and what i
would do is just
in this situation um because it is at a
collection agency you can have
you can go two ways here you choose how
you pay it off
if you morally want to pay the full
balance then you pay the full balance if
you morally want to do it if i was in
your shoes
um i'm calling them and i'm settling uh
for whatever's the lowest price they'll
be willing to settle for all right so
for an example
if you owe eighteen hundred dollars
between three credit cards i'm gonna try
and get it down to where i pay about a
thousand dollars
and push it out there with your car repo
they're probably not going to settle
um as much because what the difference
is is
uh you probably turned the car in with
it for an example for 15
000 they sold it for 4 200 you owe the
remaining balance of 10
800 but in that situation i've seen some
car
repo companies collection agencies go
down to where they'll settle in a dollar
for like fifty seven hundred dollars so
i would just jump on the phone with
these agencies and say hey
what are you willing to settle this for
out right now cash um i will send you a
certified money check
um or a money order uh you sure it's up
to you what you want to do just
no matter what do not give them a check
over the phone do not give them
a debit card over the phone you need a
letter
in hand before you settle it so that way
it is in writing and you send them a
certified money order with a tracking
number
confirming that they have it with the
copy of the letter that
that they sent you uh to settle it out
but i agree you need to
you need to pay it off so that way this
can be behind you you can move forward
um and then from there you know how to
follow the rest of the baby steps
all right can anything yeah you pay it
off you've got the money paid off
instantly yeah i mean this is
yeah i know it's a lot of money but it's
also a lot of debt you wipe off with
one fell swoop don't even think twice
about it i think your advice is great
but do it today
i would not i wouldn't even go to sleep
on it i'd do it today absolutely